come on now who you gonna call under the
lake the latest episode of Doctor Who to
air it is the first part of a two-part
is their second story I am gonna say I
like that we're getting more two-parters
more serialized stories this series
because it gives more room for these
stories to breathe and one of the things
that that happens sometimes is that they
those can feel very rushed and there are
certainly some ideas that have happened
in the last years that I'm like that
would have been so much better if it
could have been paced a little bit more
leisurely and I feel like they're
picking stories to do as the two parters
that really take advantage of be
stretched out over a longer time frame I
like this is a mystery about this
episode because it doesn't feel like
cheap mystery it feels very genuine like
we've from pretty much the first time we
see the oh I guess I'll put up spoiler
warning from here on out overall I liked
it so going on from there but when we
first started seeing the ghosts you know
they're they're talking and we can't
hear a single thing the same but
obviously they're saying something so we
know there's a piece of this puzzle
we're missing and I kind of like the way
the episode sort of dangles in front of
us showing you exactly what you don't
know yet we'll fill this in later don't
worry and that's just the vibe I got
from that from the writing on the wall I
think this is pretty cleverly laying it
out and pretty well paced I really like
the cliffhanger at the end I saw it
coming probably about maybe five seconds
sooner than I was in supposed to see it
coming but that's still a really good
cliffhanger because you find yourself
wondering well how the heck did that
happen how do we get out of that I mean
obviously we're gonna get out of that we
always do but that's a heck of a
situation to leave us in way better than
the cliffhanger that was used back in
the magician's apprentice the doctors
doing that I'm really intrigued and I'm
loving this because it's something I
don't know thing that the doctor dozen
times and it's something I've always
loved the supporting cast not exception
I mean they're they're fine there's
nothing wrong with them but these sorts
of situations like the one that
immediately comes to mind as a
comparison point is the impossible
planet in the Satan pit and the
that comparison that the supporting team
on that one they felt like a cohesive
unit felt like and crew you felt the
chemistry you felt the history between
them I don't really get that with a lot
of the scrum even as I said they're fine
there's nothing wrong with them but it
just it doesn't gel the way a lot of the
really good supporting casts have in
previous episodes I mean even last
series a lot of those episodes had
fantastic supporting casts flatline
mummy on the Orient Express those were
phenomenal supporting cast because for
as little time as they got they felt
like fully fleshed out characters they
felt like they had history they had
chemistry with each other these ones
they're just kind of there and they're
you know they're not poorly acted or
anything but they it doesn't feel like
there's a lot of meat to them I kind of
like that that pause moment that
happened inside the TARDIS with Clara
and the doctor where the doctor was kind
of like you need to stop you need to
stop acting like me and I feel like
that's probably our first bit of solid
foreshadowing for whatever the
circumstances end up being for Clara
leaving the TARDIS so I like feeling
that Ceaser getting planted in a more
character-driven away not in sort of the
blatant way that Russell T Davies used
to plan sees like just repeating bad
wolf or Torchwood or mr. Saxon over and
over and over again until we find out
what that means the ghost I like it's a
simple design but it's effective and
they're just they're just appropriately
creepy it's a creepy look I mean overall
this is just a really good set up
episode which is what the first half of
a good two-parter should be but
ultimately it's all gonna come down to
the payoff this is gonna weigh heavily
on what the conclusion ends up being and
what the answers end up being more so
than the last two-parter Magician's
apprentice I think was a pretty good
episode well I mean there were some
issues with it but it was a pretty solid
episode unto itself even though it ended
on a cliffhanger this one it feels much
more like this is the first half the
story's not done and again nothing wrong
with that but it makes this harder to
judge as a thing unto itself it does
definitely make me want to see the rest
of the story so it's doing its job
pretty well and one other random note
the thing with the cards the car had
like written out I guess sort of more
human or humane responses from the
doctor to use as reference
that was a weird moment and I didn't
like it cuz I'm fine with the doctor not
necessarily you know picking up cues for
when to say certain things or not
knowing what to save it if he picks up
on the cues but having cards on hand
back that doesn't feel right it doesn't
feel like him it does it was just an odd
moment it felt like something somebody
pitched that a story meaning at one
point they just could never figure out a
good place to put in so they just stuck
it in a random episode it feels out of
character for the doctor doesn't seem
like the sort of thing he'd agreed to it
honestly seems somewhat out of character
for Clara cuz it doesn't seem like the
kind of thing that she would try to make
him do to conform to being more normal I
guess and especially in an episode where
she's so gung-ho for the adventure and
the weirdness it was just it was odd it
was out of place it was a throwaway joke
that didn't work
and I probably just spent more time
talking about it then was warranted
overall though like I said really really
good set up excited to see what happens
next
have you seen under the lake what were
your thoughts on it whatever they were
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned